hey there thank you for tuning into
GameSpot after dark on YouTube down
below we have an entire list of
timestamps for the episode so if you
want to skip to something you're more
than welcome to and make sure to send us
emails at after dark podcast at Gamescom
so we can answer them in the show thank
you
[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 26 of
GameSpot after dark my name is Jake
Decker and this is GameSpot's official
podcast joining me this week is Lucy
James host of the unofficial GameSpot
podcast not really imagine if we had one
imagine if someone was doing like a
pirate
James foot podcast I'd be up for that
that's what this was supposed to this
was originally supposed to be the
unofficial podcast but then they were
gamespot was like what are we gonna do
with that what should we do with an
unofficial podcast so then it got folded
into being the official podcast of
gamespot.com also hi also joining is
Kelly playing hi and joining us this
week all the way from IGN Zack Ryan
that's me I'm hosting the follow up
podcast of the unofficial podcast where
we go in and break down all the stuff
that happened in the unofficial pod okay
yes it's called
GameSpot after after dark after warning
after pirate after dark yes tell tell
tell our other podcasts that we're
working on that's an email chain we're
trying to figure out now yes I'm just
gonna get that - it's like 25 emails in
wait what are you trying for I know the
podcast
yeah don't worry about it we've already
got it we've got the name right secret I
better get a writer's credit I mean do
they do writers credits for titles why
not it's got to be a really good title
that is a good title precedent I nailed
it yeah Zack who are you where are you
from this is the Chris from Dayton Ohio
segment by the way Chris yeah I work at
IGN I'm the director of social content
and strategy over there um I had been
there for about five years had a brief
stint elsewhere I was at Ubisoft for a
little bit but yeah I've been on the
video team now I run the social team and
now I'm here big fan of the show been
listening since episode one so I know
all your inside jokes and stuff and also
we've been friends for year it's cool to
come up the street and get to talk to
you guys about games and stuff
especially Kali right you've known Kali
absolutely longer than I've known any
unknown Cali since 2014
yeah mm-hmm you were on your own social
team right when I the first time yeah
yeah what a tangled web tiny industry
well yeah for audience because I'm an
avid fan of the show I did put together
a list so I wanted to make sure that I
had the list readily available and of
course I do not listen to every yeah
yeah so I just made a list of my
favorite games just kind of off the top
of my head so Super Mario RPG
Sonic the Hedgehog Donkey Kong 3
Adventures of Lolo adventures I told
Lucy that I was gonna do that a couple
nights ago like I got this great goop
I'd forgotten that you told me that what
does that - goof that you would do here
and I thought you might read out you're
weird like you're insanely viral tweet
or it's like quick everyone was I
thought you're gonna just read out that
but this is someone right well that's
actually the other thing that I pulled
up so I'm like my favorite games wind
waker vagrant story Metal Gear Solid and
super mario world breath of the wild
blood-borne Symphony of the Night yeah I
like a lot of character action games
like a lot of JRPGs yeah that's Zelda
Nintendo anything I also like I'm a co
so the Nintendo voice chat podcast at
IGN so a big Nintendo boy yeah
that was excellent thank you we talked
about that video
it's come up a couple times okay I don't
think we've said what it is it was more
just like some of our listeners might
know what this is and I think we got a
couple emails and tweets from people
being like because you write out a list
of people who got it
right I think so yeah at some point so
to keep in tradition I don't think we
can say what that is
oh okay stop see from yeah it's yeah
something that I watched still to this
day like once once a week probably
pinnacle of comedy tree I have it saved
offline like I downloaded it No so [ __ ]
burn it onto a CD like I would go analog
HS keep in a fireproof box yeah no so
it's because I remember seeing it online
years ago and I just like just never
thought about it and then May 2018 I
remember being sat in an apartment in LA
with Joey and tomorrow saying I was like
what the hell is that skit and I spent
ages like it was definitely the Wii Shop
and like found it after about a
half-hour because I had a lot going on
and and ever since then I was like I can
never forget this again you can never
lose this this precious moment if you're
out there and you find it good for you
congratulations
[Laughter]
anyway we start this show off with what
we've been playing and then we'll move
on to topics where we've got some news
stories plus a lot of us played the
disintegration beta disintegration beta
I think we've got some thoughts on that
spicy takes and then we wrap up with
listener questions but before we do that
we talked about what we've been playing
what we've been doing Lucy do you wanna
start us out here no Lucy's the segue
let go I'll go last cuz I'll be I'll be
the segue okay Kelly do you wanna start
then sure I I've been playing Pokemon
still I won't go on about that too much
because I always talk about it but we
are working on a competitive Pokemon
explainer video that's like explainer
videos videos so you'd like it's like a
video series about getting into
competitive pokemon that's pretty cool
yeah let me write that down
[Laughter]
so I've been like doing stuff
specifically for that that series like
what's really cool too is that I so
we've recorded the audio and you had you
broke down Eevee's IVs and all that
stuff in under seven minutes which is
how fast were you talking pretty unheard
of because when I was doing some
research a lot of guides for the for
this kind of they're like 45 minutes to
an hour I come from a family of teachers
so that's what my parents are poke or my
father's side her Pokemon trainers and
my mother's teachers my mother was a
Machamp so yeah I am excited about that
and then I started watching The Outsider
so good and we've all been watching it
yeah because I love Stephen King and I
like stuff about murders i theory murder
inna i mean white the murder inna right
and it's it's cool it's like the first
episode was so much courrier than i
thought it would be
yeah there's definitely some like the
real five minutes and then it like stops
being gory but i was kind of like then i
said did i tell the story about when i
tried to wash your weird chin saying
whatever my drunk chicken your chicken
Tandy's yeah and then that the dead body
comes up I was like one too drunk for
this conduit something I'd to try it
again the next day when I was sober and
not eating chicken it's a good show yeah
I I also like watch the first four
episodes on Sunday like straight running
because after now after the first
episode I think oh I have to I have to
know in fact I think I texted you I was
like I'm desperate to know what's
happening in this show like because the
mystery is centers yeah the mystery at
the center of the show is like so weird
and interesting is that it sure I mean
it's a kind of did last week but I want
to do it again briefly but it's like
it's in Georgia and a child gets
murdered and everyone thinks they have a
slam dunk on the case and that it's
gonna be the Asha yeah
it's the loved baseball coach oh yeah
because I called it something else I
call it basketball didn't I you didn't
call it basketball american sports but
it just takes such a - yeah like and I
feel like it takes a turn in like every
episode right like yeah every episode
there's something where you're like what
what now this - cuz I love the character
the private investigator who is a savant
as well I love her so she's very good
yeah that's a very Stephen King s
character - oh yeah there's a lot of
things like we had to look up when it
was written because I was like like some
of the dialogue not in a bad way some of
the dialogue was just like there's
something uh somebody in the 80s would
say but not now like it just feels like
old man dialogue a little bit to me
Stephen King so and it's just but it
wasn't it wasn't written the eighties it
just has like 2018 really really really
but Stephen King just has a very
particular style which is what I like
about him but yeah I'm very much
enjoying it it's always nice to get more
cuz like I don't know if you I really
liked the stand when I was in high
school yes favorite that was my favorite
Stephen King book it was actually one of
my favorite books that I'd read it was
like a thousand pages and I was like I'm
a genius
and my parents are like oh you should
watch the terrible TV series oh my god
with Molly Ringwald mmm Gary since the
nice yeah a lot has HBO adapted a
Stephen King novel before is this the
first time they're doing it I think that
a tree I mean CBS oh I find I mean we're
part of the fine Viacom CBS family but
CBS all access is doing the stand
so I'm excited coming out this year next
year I think they're giving it the full
HBO treatment I guess like it a limited
miniseries three Miam programming
premium programming I was all access I
got like half way into the first episode
of The Outsider by the way and I was
like is that Jason Bateman like yeah he
looks like a bad
yeah he's in a bad situation in that
show yeah
but Lucy's the one who was like and
watched at first and then Jake could
wash it and then yeah I did actually
trace it back because I don't remember I
don't remember beat there being that
much buzz about it and that's all I
don't even think I remember seeing a
trailer I just had text my friend Sam
who was like me he's back in the UK so
he's like me get on this it's Bateman
cuz me and him both love Ozark and he
was like okay babe ins be doing another
weird thing this is really good by
mendelssohn's in it and yeah so shadows
my friend's head so he directed a bunch
of the episodes really cool too
yeah he is a fantastic director like if
you seen the video we talked about
briefly last week but when he won the
Emmy over Game of Thrones and he's just
going Wow okay yeah PC really seems like
the kind of guy that you could just like
have a beer with and yeah yeah he seems
like a cool dude yeah yeah not a macho
again the fine HBO programming segment
on this podcast I know I just because I
feel like with HBO you can just kind of
pick whatever and it's guaranteed to be
pretty dang good detective season 2 not
very good okay His Dark Materials also
not very good cuz like I feel like
Netflix releases new shows every week if
not every day and most of them just suck
even if your dad doesn't have Netflix he
probably has HBO so you can easily mooch
off your parents uh-huh uh-huh that's
true I'm on my dad's Netflix and HBO so
I have the opposite problem obviously I
can't share my HBO account with them
right HBO that service doesn't exist in
the UK it's part of Sky TV so I have
Netflix and I have like most of my
family on there and they all have their
own all their are not the characters and
then for Christmas every year it really
annoys me that they asked me for DVDs of
the crown I'm not even kidding I was
like
that's aggressively British yes could
say that's are okay that's like if my
dad was like can you get me tapes at the
Bears game for me no or like if I did
give a gift to someone who lived in Bret
and I probably the crown on DVD probably
like yeah but then we stop talking about
it cuz my stepmom won yeah I was like
what do you think of Megamall cause I
don't then you referred to makes it as
the elephant in the room ones yeah can
we talk about the elephant in the room
and she's like what like what's going on
with Megan like why are they leaving I
understand it's very important stuff to
me personally yeah I had a moment like
that where my mom comes to me for like
what's the what's the buzz on the social
issues you know like what how do you use
they/them pronouns and I'm Michael
here's how you do it and she was like
what do you think about that and I was
like I'm not touching that anything
about that
you're gonna have to ask somebody else
you're gonna have a stay my aunt and I
had this great conversation we talked
about met God talking about Megan and
Harry then it led on to Diana being
murdered I was like okay interesting
interesting then she was like I don't
think we went to the moon I think that
was a lie also the earth round round and
like like if somebody's like I don't
think we went to the moon you're you
could just escalate so you go you
believe in the moon yeah I love that
anyway
howdy writer good show HM very good
Zak very interested to see I do we know
how long how many episodes what the run
is 10/10 addictive so there are six more
episodes so that means that that show is
really gonna go places because at the
end of the fourth episode there's
something that happens at the end that
you're like oh that now the show is
gonna be a completely different thing
yeah yeah yeah and we're just cool it I
like it being Stephen King you kind of
expect that which is good because I
so the endings gonna be shy yeah yeah
bummer I love Stephen get like I love
Stephen King he is pretty much all I
read throughout my teenage years my mind
can't stick and ending hey that was the
only good part of it chapter 2 the old
man and was like the writer sucks at
writing endings and I was like ah
everyone was like this movie didn't suck
no it still did but that scene was very
good although the ending of the shining
and the original novel was pretty good
with the explosion like the Kubrick
ending better the same I mean I like him
both but I'm just saying he didn't he
didn't mess that one up how about The
Shining adaptation for network
television
oh the one that Stephen King wrote
because he was so annoyed about the
treehouse of horror
yeah that's shitty for this [ __ ] just
use that [ __ ] over sued Zack what have
you been playing up to yeah so I've
recently dedicated my life to my Lord
and Savior Smash Brothers
what I'd like to yeah I am gonna play
some after this yeah doc totally down I
so I have complicated relationship with
smash as a die-hard Nintendo fan I've
always I've always really loved the idea
that it's like Oh Princess Peach
fighting link in starfox land like
that's pretty amazing on corneria like I
love the mashup of like Nintendo
franchises I think is as a like a
[Music]
essentially a product showcase for
Nintendo it's brilliant because like how
many kids played smash brothers on Wii
and we're like who are all these Fire
Emblem boys and then like went out and
played Fire Emblem right so I think it's
it's probably the best piece of
marketing Nintendo has ever made and it
also turns out it's a really great
fighting game I'm absolutely terrible at
it I'm so bad at it and I'm just awful
and I played a lot of ultimate when it
came out I played through world of Light
played a lot like you know in the office
cuz like a ton people in the office are
playing it I played a lot here you know
and then just completely fell off it
like didn't play any of the expansion
packs or anything and then after the
buyeth direct
I was home on a Saturday and I was
walking down the hall and my roommate
was playing and he's like yeah that
direct really got me jazz for smash like
I'm you know I was lonely one yeah and
and he's like you want to play and he's
a key okay and I ended up sitting and
playing with him for like six hours and
then played all day the next day and by
the end of the weekend I was like okay
this is it I'm gonna get good at this
like I really want to get good at Smash
Brothers and so like I've been playing a
lot of smash and I went through and you
know played all the new characters and
stuff but I played by lift last night at
launch or at release pretty cool
character feels to me like a slower
version of young link like a similar
move set that's my main I main young
link so I love that she has like all of
the relics
yes word and the accident in Claude's
bow yeah and I'm like nope by no means a
professional or or have any right to
have an opinion on how the character
plays like competitively seems like
there's some like really Opie stuff and
remove set that I'm this kind of
interesting you down be is like super
slow but you can you can critical like
you can get a kill confirm at like sixty
percent like yeah her aerial stuff is
really vicious with the with like yeah
Call of Duty lingo I think that is vile
earth is interesting because violence
moves are all super strong yeah but a
lot of them you have to plan and I feel
like in one-on-one situations by oath
probably isn't super good just because
the other person in theory should be
anticipating a lot of those rows and
they should see them coming and be able
to get out of the way but in multiplayer
we found with like four people buyeth is
very deadly because that arrow in
particular is incredibly strong you can
switch directions you can switch
directions it's hard to if you do it
fast enough so her has two levels of
charge and in the first level you can if
you flick the stick the opposite
direction she'll flip directions and you
know aim her air the other way which
like you can't do with other characters
yeah and what's also crazy is like young
link right when young link fires arrow
boy see that arrow with violet it's just
a line that just like shoots across the
screen I don't know if there's a range
on it we didn't planning big enough max
like hit
and versus it kind of seems that way I
mean it's not white skin because I think
it's still like does have a path that
travels but it is pretty good now can we
talk about the elephant in the room haha
makes it makes it no they definitely
made your boobs smaller oh really
I'm pretty sure wait I'm trying to think
of an elephant boo pun and it's it's
never I mean you're not wrong smash bros
ultimate has a history of nerfing well I
was gonna say but because snakes but
snakes but got mad nerfed yeah they're
there they're not down with the
thickness over and then we could talk
about zero suit samus but but she still
looks great it's fine but yeah yeah
snakes but is missing is it true they do
look are you doing a compare and
contrast on the boobs the boobs babe
yeah I think it also like in my mind
violet is canonically female because I
played Fire Emblem as female buyeth and
so when I came to the air yeah when it
came to the character selection screen
last night like get the hell out of here
man why this is not a complaint
obviously because a lot of the color
schemes aren't like one to one with like
alternate costumes or anything but the
green hair is definitely so discolored
and not violet colored mm yeah one of
them is supposed to be so discolor but
the other one is supposed to be like the
violet I don't wanna spoil it but you
know like what happens and yeah through
the game but yeah what you're saying it
doesn't look like it and what's also
kind of a bummer is that you can't play
female buyeth with with what are their
names I already forgot their names the
house lead the male House leaders Claude
yeah you can't play female BIOS with
their colors okay let go go yeah because
you can only play as edelgard edelgard
no guards color because it's best color
scheme no yeah it's true so I'm okay
with that but it would have been nice
timon Hossein has
with a boob boob pun that boobs are not
truncated there it is well done tomorrow
thank you very much we can always count
on some more for a good pun
yeah even from beyond the grave he's not
he's with the voice of God I just saw
him he was taking pictures of us like a
minute ago now he's dead uh I think of
the expansion characters she's probably
the most vanilla just in terms of like
hero has all his like magic meter
juggling Terry is very final fight
focused like very hardcore fighting and
then you've got Joker and banjo which
are like the interesting move sets but
more so just like kind of mind-blowing
that they're in the game period yeah
exactly and so it's like as a character
she's we were talking about this on NBC
today but as a character she's neither
of those things you know it's not like
super technical and it's not like super
surprising so she just sort of is and I
think that's totally fine like I I
really like the way she controls I think
that of those characters in the
expansion the first expansion pass I'd
probably pick her every time hmm also I
just love fire on them so that game so
good I saw a really want to go back to
three houses I played a little bit this
weekend but I don't I saw a great tweet
of someone who was mad that they added
bio with me like this is just marketing
they're just marketing the new DLC
coming out and then just all the
responses are just like yeah that's
every character and I'm one of those
people the only game I had played before
I played Super Smash Bros was Pokemon
and then I played Super Smash Bros and
then I was like okay I got to play Mario
64 now I got to play the the Superman I
got to play Metroid games and I went
down that list except for Captain Falcon
because yeah I mean I good game now a
lot of games
I played smash before I played a Zelda
game like and then I knew me too
actually
yeah same with me and obviously Fire
Emblem and like I was so it's the thing
is they got me so early with being in
love with Fire Emblem characters
with Martin oh yeah because you know
such a weeb that finding weebo that's
not mine I think that's a time special
but it's like we got to make that show
happen mm-hmm like I remember with melee
when they added Marth and Roy and it was
super surprising because it was like who
are these sword right characters they
the what game is this from that's not
he's dashing swords yeah and and then
they decided to add a dozen more yeah my
favorite my favorite tweet after that
direct was Jason fryers tweet where it
was like expansion past too and it was
like Adel guard and then like four more
characters from Fire Emblem and then the
last the last fighter was just like a
bunch of swords yeah so I've been
playing a lot of smash I started
Jacquizz a zero I've not been into the
Yaquis of series previously get in early
host club minigame Oh that shit's so
laughs okay I could take a look at that
but I'm really enjoying
yahooza and Jake I know that you are a
big dragon quest 11 s fan again I've
been playing that since it launched on
switch very slowly like that game is
built in a way that it tells story arcs
it's almost like in it like an anime arc
and then so it makes for really natural
stopping points and so like I'll stop
and go and play some Yakuza for a week
or so and then come back to Dragon Quest
and play through another arc and like
what a fantastic game like what a
beautiful funny I'm not a Dragon Quest
guy I've never I mean I am now but yeah
this is the only Dragon Quest I've
played actually actually I played a
little bit eight three I'm not into
Dragon Quest like actually I've played
this one and this one yeah I did play a
Dragon Quest game on des called rocket
slime
oh yeah rocket slimes cool which I loved
I thought that Kiyoshi I am a Dragon
Quest a lot of Dragon Quest builders oh
alright
so we're the same person and they're the
same thing well yeah that game that game
is very good oh so good really quickly
we don't have to I just want you to give
a shout-out to shits Creek because oh
yeah me want to watch it telling me
about it on Saturday and the name made
me not want to watch right so please
give us an elevator yeah so I'm I
started it I don't know three weeks ago
and I'm already dying with ya thanks to
Lucy this is again just a true
translation a real tastemaker Lucy James
on Sunday I had you and friend of the
show Andrew Goldfarb texted me about the
outsider
and then you guys are telling me on
Monday that you'd watched it and I was
like can I also tell you that any time
we mentioned Andrew Goldfarb on IGN
podcasts we also say friend of the show
I mentioned him on I did
PS I love you xoxo like a week or two
ago and I said friend of the show and
he's a friend of every show but he
texted me and he's like oh your friend
of the show shout out and I was
are you not listening to the but no
shits Creek is uh yeah I think it's one
of the funniest sweetest sitcoms maybe
ever made and yeah like what I was
saying to you I the name completely
turned me off like the name is so
unfunny a name that I was just like I
don't want to watch that for five
seasons and now I'm like almost done
with the whole series and he's overtaken
me oh yeah oh yeah the thing you said to
me that was that it was like The
Simpsons in like the way the comedy is
it's like The Simpsons in the way that
like you'll laugh it's something so
stupid and then the next moment will be
such a wholesome moment that you're like
oh that's really sweet and also by the
time you get to probably the second or
third season every line of dialogue is a
joke every line is a joke and it's like
funny in the way that it calls back to
stuff like Arrested Development and it's
funny in the way that it is just like
compounds jokes within an episode like
it's really really smart writing what's
it about um so it's about a wealthy
family that gets basically like charged
with tax evasion their their their money
handler basically screws them in the
very first episode you don't even see it
happen like the first episodes opens
with them having all their stuff
repossessed and they have to go live in
this the only thing that doesn't get
repossessed is the dad bought an entire
town called shits Creek as a joke for
his eldest that the son like he's like
he bought a town as a joke and then they
have to live there because that's the
only thing that they own and so they end
up like living in this hotel but then
they end up like really coming to like
the whole first season as them just be
like we have to get out of here we have
to get out this is terrible but they
make all these relationships and they
adapt like small town life and like it's
just very wholesome and like very very
funny
yeah it's gracious Catherine O'Hara is
amazing that's why watching is because
there was this compilation that just got
algorithmically delivered to me and it
was a boy fish it's creeks best moments
and it's just everything like this the
voice that she talks is this weird like
elect Asian yeah her mouth is very
strong
Atlantic Atlantic there we go yeah it's
like trying to be British yeah yeah but
she uses all these weird old words that
you just don't hear off anymore like
straight petty flog heady flogging no
since you just write to me was wigs yeah
she just has so many wigs she's she's an
act like her backstory in the shows that
she's like a former actress like like
daytime actress and in the show there's
this long running gag about how she's in
a movie called the crows have eyes like
for for promotion of the last season
they just released the trailer for the
crows have eyes three and it's one of
the funniest things I've ever seen it's
amazing this whole show is just like so
so funny I'm sold on Saturday when we're
hanging out for tomorrow's birthday
party right
happy birthday Tam I was like I gotta
prioritize this show yeah nice there you
go all right should I say what you wanna
end playing two things yeah journey to
the South not here that smash is not
relevant okay so why we are saying
waiting as myself or just playing
Pokemon I've been played [ __ ] Lucy just
change your handle Lucy James doesn't
play games Oh sick not a gamer good for
you I've been playing door I was playing
during to the savage planet oh that's
what I was talking about last week that
I was like I can't talk about this whole
evening to that game is really good it's
basically a I mean Metroid Prime is
colorful but it is a very colorful
vibrant funny Metroid Prime no kidding
much shorter I like I haven't finished
it yet my save got reset I don't know
how it happened I'm kind of annoyed but
I think it was because I had a PC build
and then they updated with a day one
patch and I think it wiped my way to my
safe but the game is short I was almost
done with it and I was I think at like 6
or 7 hours like 10 hours
yeah if you're like really taking your
time but the thing that's really cool
about it I think which is weird because
it's something they weren't really
pushing when they were like telling
press about it is is co-op because co-op
is a lot of fun in how you interact with
the environment how your partner
interacts with the environment like an
example is you have bait and these
little animals will like basically
attack the bait so I can throw it on my
buddy and then the animals would just
swarm them and attack them until they
die or Rob and I were playing a little
bit and I was throwing explosive plants
at him while he was trying to he's
trying to get through the section and
you just fly off and die but what is
this so it's a lot of fun it's uh I
definitely recommend playing with a
friend like I'm sure I played a good
amount single plant it was still fun and
there was like it is a good sense of
humor but playing in multi co-op is just
something that I don't know I feel like
I haven't really had a co-op experience
quite like that before I'm sure there
are plenty things out there you could
compare to it but it's just like a very
solid Metroidvania with some funny
moments and great co-op I don't know
anything about this game with 2d 3d it's
3d you're exploring just one planet okay
you're you're working for a space
exploration company it's like the third
bests the fourth best space exploration
is pretty fun company crash on a planet
it's not supposed to be it's not
supposed to be there's an especially any
alien life on there turns out there's a
lot and basically you get there and
they're like oh there's a tower you have
to go to that tower nerd fix your ship
and you have to traverse this dangerous
world it's not super dangerous like the
combat is probably my least favorite
thing about the game overall which I
think what you guys okay to read but I
would definitely recommend playing it
with a friend for sure I like such
Tintin's studio yes cool yeah so typhoon
yeah that's the big thing I've been
playing and then I started and then I
started Kentucky route zero last night
route or route really I think yeah we
talked about the gate I always I've
always said route because oh do you say
route 60
six I don't I say route 66 but if I'm
talking about routes in Pokemon I say
we're out one route to but I've been
sent Kentucky route zero anyway the word
vexes me which one Kentucky Kentucky
hates the south but yeah like the game
you would say continue okay
I only say route I can't do it and try
see it out
I prefer sing route because come on you
sit in the ground yeah that's like
routes not power Ione would ever say
route if it's like in Fire Emblem like
route the enemy because route enemies I
don't know have you seen those boobs I
read the word before I had really heard
it because I was reading Pokemon guides
that's fine and that's not so wholesome
yeah so how much how much have you
played of Kentucky route zero like an
hour I played it on barges first chapter
or not even the first chapter like the
first two scenes of the first chapter so
far I like it a lot
it is very haunting ethereal kind of
strange but Kurt has talked a lot about
it because he's a big fan of that game
and he's been following since the
beginning but just the way the
characters are just kind of there for
the ride and they don't question a lot
of the weird thing that weird things
that are happening yeah but it also
doesn't really draw attention to the
fact that there's weird things happening
it's just kind of like I'm a guy trying
to deliver this package on a route that
may not exist but it's super neat it's
definitely my style of game I think the
the writing so far I'm very into yeah I
mean yeah I'm really stoked to play this
- I think it's definitely one of those
games that you know it's been in
development so long and has episodic
releases and stuff that I every time the
new one has come out it's been like I'll
wait until it's fish saying ah wait
until it's finished to play it even
though every time I see it I'm like this
is very much my [ __ ] like got really
interested in this I played it at PAX
East in 2015 or 16 on switch that was
like the last time yeah Peck's West yeah
that matter we might have been at the
same one but um yeah I'm really stoked
to play this game and everybody that we
gave it an eight at IGN and everybody
that is playing it now on switch is like
yeah it's fantastic like I really like
the idea that all this weird cosmic
stuff is happening but the characters
are sort of like non-plus by it the
music is fantastic too like early on
there's a scene where the camera zooms
out and there's like a band just playing
in the background and you get that music
and it's like do you want to continue
and I just sat there and waited and let
them finish the song because the music
was really good like strange was a
really good moment like that I think in
the first first series when you were
playing you can just sit with Chloe on
the bed and like you can either like hit
button and get up or you can just lie
there and listen to the song like a lot
of moment like the ABS are like BioShock
Infinite to free on PS Plus is February
yes a whole Bioshock collection damn
that's a good deal yeah it is I will say
I'm playing on switch light and the stat
screen seems a little too small for that
kind of game yeah I I was like I'm gonna
buy this on switch of court like that's
a no-brainer of course I'm gonna get
this on switch and I started playing on
switch light and I was like I might just
pick this up on my or I might just
switch to my regular Doc's which and
play it on a TV or at least a bigger
screen because some of the characters
and texts are pretty small yeah I was
worried about that with Fire Emblem and
you said it was okay yeah I played a bit
of fire in this weekend and it didn't
seem to bother me as much as I thought
it would before I had played it are you
new to the switch light no I got it when
it came out I just was done with fire at
that point I guess in Jenna and I
thought about it and I was like oh I'll
play it again sometime and then I played
a bit this weekend and I was like yeah I
was fine the full release of Kentucky
route zero is called TV edition so
playing the game there yeah yeah I heard
it's like pretty visually stunning as
well yeah that's good yeah that's it for
me though oh hi everyone looks at me uh
in terms what I've been playing on doing
so when see if I win see 19:17 really
won with you tomorrow on Monday did you
like it Oh
go ahead oh no what are you gonna so we
saw with Tim and the movie is very
intense it's a very intense but I've
seen it before
and like I was very excited to see the
second time we sawed an IMAX like
pin-drop silence the whole time like
just like everybody just wrapped in what
we were watching except for me eating
that sandwich yeah in the beginning the
moment but credits roll Tam leans over
to me and he goes
Tim Mendez how long you been waiting to
say that one he's like about 10 minutes
in is it so I really really wanted to
see it and it just like it came out here
but I was traveling and then I went back
to the UK and then it didn't come out in
the UK or at least I missed it and then
I came back here and by the time I sort
of thought to go see it again it went
out of the cinema for about a week which
is last week so I went to see knives out
instead which was fine like it wasn't oh
no oh I really liked it and I have a
vomit phobia oh god I remember I'm
watching I was like it's a lot but I
actually still like to the movie I liked
it a lot I just kind of saw where it was
going very early so I was like oh yeah I
think it Telegraph's that yeah it does
tell him everybody it just meant like
for me the enjoyment was also Dale Craig
was great
no you didn't like to handle cray i
reconsidering a lot here
I don't really know he was good but I
felt like Jamie Lee curse was massively
wasted in that movie she was fantastic
it was like okay by god she was so good
at Halloween anyway so when she touches
have seen because deacons I wanted to
see it and like the fact that it was in
IMAX and I got my Apple watch because I
lent it to you and you gave it back and
one of the things I used to love doing
it's quite sad I did tweet by this is
that I love watching what my heart rate
does doing movies and I used to do this
playing blood-borne I think I tweeted it
at the time but it was like it's just me
playing blood-borne and it's spikes
because of a box or something so if you
look at my I tweeted out my heart rate J
19:17 is like fine elevates because wydo
elevates a bit goes by down and then the
end I can't do like 108 beats per minute
because I was so stressed I'm just sad
that like this the whole time it's
fantastic it's such a good movie it's
very I cried fully yeah it's really
really good the music is also very good
the cinematography the one-shot stuff
and it's like Birdman in that you can't
you can see some of them but like cuts
yeah you see some guys but you don't
they hide it really well they hide it
super well and what the one shot brings
to it is so much more like that's so
much more important then you try to look
for the cuts if that makes sense
well because also the timeline in that
movie is very very short
it takes place it takes place over the
course of like 14 hours or something so
the the idea that it's all one shot
leads you to you know it just helps sell
the idea that like this is a very short
period of time that like all this [ __ ]
is happening in so it's like you I can
say the S word right I can see yeah okay
I know I've said several times but is
that like the largest scale film that is
like in one shot cuz like there are
definitely more but but this seems like
a far bigger scale than that
yeah I would say it's a lot of there's a
obviously there's way way more action in
this movie they're not yeah
then Birdman yes that cinematography
those killer cinematography delicious
but what I've been playing and the
segues nicely into the the topics the
news I was in the disintegration not
just a song by The Cure and I'll say
beat her god damn it none of this [ __ ]
doesn't bother me
PlayStation Vita no she's gonna move
past that huh
something I've taken notes because like
okay so if you don't know what
disintegration is probably do that often
it's um the co-creator of Halo Marcus
Leto his new studios v1 published by
private division a subsidiary of take 2
entertainment what is it it's like I did
so I this is just the multiplayer beta
you basically I looked into the story
stuff the story stuff sounds cool in
that it's very altered carbon in the
human brains downloaded into machines
etc etc you control a graph cycle so
it's basically like this floating ship
mech thing unfortunately as a diva main
didn't feel good to me at all if you're
talking about a piloted mech or
titanfall
god it just made me want to play
titanfall but so you so you play that
for a first-person perspective you're in
this mech but at the same time you have
these RTS elements and that you're
controlling little units yeah it's a
small squad depending on like which
grabs ichael crew yeah you get a
different crew that has I think
different abilities and so going in the
technical b2 I'd be interested it
because times are something different
okay the PlayStation beer uh when you go
into the training I played as this graph
cycle who had sort of dual pistols that
felt like tracers gun
like very rapid fire smg's quick reload
not that much not high damage but it was
cool and my kind of I don't I'm loath to
say ultimate ability but like my
secondary fire was putting a grenade
down that he had an area in fact and
he'll that wasn't in the actual playable
multiplayer so why am I being trained on
a mech that I can't well I imagine you I
imagine that that training is the story
mode training yeah they just cut that
section out and pasted it in front of
the access to the actual multiple like
that there are at least one very similar
yes you can't you don't have those dual
guns which ones the jewel but you do
have that secondary okay which is I
think the Knights have that one anyway
so you're kind of going some multiplayer
and it's two modes there's gonna be
three modes eventually there - one of
them is a basically zone capture yeah
domination domination and then the other
one was payload deliver a payload one
god I'm trying so hard not to say
overwatch terms as far well no I got so
frustrated with it I had to play
overwatch after Justin calm myself she
had to and then I had to play overwatch
and then I got play of the game sorry
I'm
going into that I mean there were cool
things that you could see we're sort of
inspired by Apex like I think the way
that they were doing their cosmetics and
unlockables very apex even the menus
kind of reminded me a lot of Apex but
when you get into the actual game itself
I don't not going to be too judgey
because it's technical beta like
actually when they said that they were
doing when they were like help us like
like breakout game essentially because
you know that's what it B is for just
didn't like the mech the graph cycle had
no weight to it so I didn't feel like I
was really doing anything when you are
in the middle of things when you're
capturing a zone for example and there's
so much going on it's not it doesn't
feel natural to try and press r1 to
direct your units because at the same
time you're trying to shoot at the other
actual person who's shooting at you
there is there are different graphs like
different crews so see like there is the
lost Ronin who I eventually kind of fell
in love with because they're alt fire
was this lock-on missile so it just
meant that everyone was using them I
played it for half an hour 45 minutes
and towards the end of that everyone
started using just that it was like
weird you could see cuz I was playing
with the same people are never and over
again because the matchmaking wasn't
giving me anyone else and by the end
everyone was just using that one grab
cycle cuz it was powered just like the
far and away the best one yeah and all
your little units have abilities too
which are on the d-pad it's not
immediately clear like the you I didn't
make it medial here what any of those
were and I was just using them but
without doing it strategically I was
just hitting up on the d-pad and then
aiming and firing it cuz I was like I'll
do something I had I had no idea what
except for the tutorial where it tells
you what they're gonna do after that
when I picked other ones I had no idea
what I was using I would just use it
because I thought well you know I gotta
use them here goes we're just gonna
throw it down here to kind of remind me
of the outer worlds in that you you know
your companions have these like special
abilities that are like concussion
grenades or you know super missile or
whatever
and ultimately what it boils down to is
just like big attack right like multiple
like Splash Damage big attack and so it
was I didn't necessarily find it
particularly unintuitive in that regard
it was just kind of like okay I just
need to damage like these five guys
right now so I'll just hit left on the
d-pad and call it a day thank ya all
right I'm not a multiplayer shooter dude
like I you know I don't play like a ton
of overwatch or apex um so I think no I
think what's interesting is that like
the way that it stacks all these like
different tasks on you like you're
really juggling a lot of things at once
you know you're it's a first-person
shooter in that you're controlling this
grab cycle and attacking these different
squads you're controlling your squad
telling them where to move you're
juggling these ultimate powers blah blah
blah um I'm more interested in the story
mode that I am in the multiplayer and I
think that could be pretty cool we this
is actually I should say this is IGN's
IGN first this month and so there's like
a ton of coverage on IGN about like the
all these different sort of aspects of
the game and the the preview right and
Tyrells like big preview for this game
is he got like an extended hands on with
the story mode and it the story sounds
pretty cool it sounds pretty interesting
and I'm I am interested to see more of
that but the multiplayer like most
multiplayer shooter is just not for me
yeah and it's a shame because like I I
know I didn't spend that much time with
it but it didn't make me want to play
any more of it that's I mean I played
like a few rounds of control I played a
few rounds of the the payload one and I
was like I think this is all I need to
see from this multiplayer like this is
not what I'm gonna be getting I think I
played about an hour I was like okay
yeah that's about how much I played it I
I do I do like multiplayer games
I don't like RTS all that much so
immediately I am more interested in just
shooting the enemies yeah and if you do
that you're at a disadvantage because
that is part of the game right you're
supposed to control your units they're
supposed to take positions for you
advance cover you which sounds cool like
maybe some people are really and maybe
that is like the perfect style of game
for someone cuz to be fair there aren't
many games like that that really exists
that blend like RTS shooter so if that's
your kind of game like maybe this is for
you but as someone who doesn't care much
for RTS is and plays a good amount of
like
shoot uh like shooters online I mean you
play like more military like closer to a
military sim then you know like it's
true I mean but I do bounce around
though right like I've been playing a
lot of Call of Duty recently which I've
talked about on this but I also played a
lot of apex when that came out played a
ton of pub G I play Rainbow six siege
all the time and I dabble in a lot of
them rarely rarely do these games get
their hooks in me except for siege and
modern warfare ISM now but this one just
after the couple games I played I fell
off pretty hard I was like nope this is
it's not my kind of game is it is it
that it's generic like I think it's I
think from what I've seen it seems very
generic I'm very I'm excited to play the
single-player because I think the
single-player is something that I could
get into especially if they're doing
like sort of really cool things like I
fell in love with Halo because I was
like so enraptured by the the sci-fi and
also the music the music makes me cry
but the music and this is actually
pretty good yes I'm enjoying it sounds
like there's something promising here I
mean did you get any of the Halo DNA
from it at all
I don't know I don't and I mean my shoe
also maybe this is just me it's that the
the the HUD is very very busy yeah and
that's there's a lot going on already in
terms of where you're juggling you know
six or seven different things the HUD
isn't doing any favors it's kind of a
bummer and it was a difficult it's not
easy to tell where you're getting shot
from which is I mean there's no hand you
like blood coming you know there's a
little thing in the middle but it's it's
kind of an orangey red so it blends in
with the the brownie backgrounds like
the map for the the zone control was aid
like a junkyard so it's very blood
Browns and like Steel's one thing I will
say that is good that I did very much
enjoy is the different crews the
aesthetic for them is really good if you
go until those menus and I look at they
all have this very distinct style and
themes and so like there's a bunch of
nights there are these Ronin there are
these like mad
yeah Tron dudes like yeah the junk rats
actually I think that in their ability
all basically bouncing bombs which is
just I I did like that and I thought
everyone that was kind of cool and yeah
like I said I I I'm excited to play the
story because I feel like even though I
said what I've seen
doesn't seem super interesting to me it
doesn't really have a lot of I don't
know character from what I've seen I
feel like maybe a lot of that would come
after add more context of like these
characters like the world were in what
happening and stuff like that also to be
fair up to a lot of the shooters that we
do like with the exception of overwatch
and apex like River succeed at first
glance exactly any character so that is
one thing I do in a clarify it has some
really cool aesthetics and I'm curious
to see what they do with it but right
now without that context I have I'm
having a very tough time like getting
invested in this multiplayer and that's
why I'm hoping you know single-player
could do that but I think even if I play
the single player in the single players
fantastic and I'm really into it
based on what I've played in this beta I
don't think I would spend a lot of time
in the multiplayer just because it
doesn't seem like it's my sort of
multiplayer like I don't want to
competitively play and RTS shooter style
cuz I'd get destroyed I'm terrible at
RTS is and I'm not that good at shooters
the two together like I just I would
fumble that every time yeah I mean that
this is what betas are for right this is
this is an opportunity for developers to
see what works and what doesn't about
their games and so like that's the most
promising thing about something like
this is like we might play this now and
down the road when it releases it might
be completely retooled and feel
different and you know
yeah like things like UI balance like
like the UI that could change that one
class that you're talking about that
everyone was picking like I'm sure
that'll change
oh yeah may I have another beer yeah I
have a cold
I think we're fresh out basically I call
I mean I'm like I'm not really an
aficionado I open it I'm like yeah let's
beer
did you want to say as evidence that um
Jake's not evidence but you said you my
favorite thing I've overheard Jake say
while playing Call of Duty was they're
beating us
they're beating us and they aren't even
using guns you don't want to know some
of the things that we say when we play
yeah we are we are one share button away
from being fully canceled just yeah like
Matt Padgett says we place two each or
if you publish things I say I just can't
swear yeah so I I break out see what all
the time when I put your British Mario
Kart yeah that's true
I go I prize that does not get the
Nintendo seal of approval yeah okay
I probably swear the most out of our
siege crew probably I think Matt though
has probably heard you curse too many
times because he's been he's been
dropping dropping the C word a couple
times and you know I don't know like
like he kind of needs to ask my
permission
right anyway anything left on
disintegration anyone's to bring up B is
open this weekend we got in a couple
days before he'll be open I think by the
time this podcast goes out
let us know what you think yeah after
that podcast that gave us what I'll come
next thing on the list thrown breakers
surprise release on switch I did I still
haven't played so I'm excited I am so
excited to play it on switch even though
it's not Gwent on switch it's kind of
Gwent on switch there's still a lot of
Gwen and I was so excited and I told so
Jen my roommate has been playing The
Witcher 3 on switch and is very excited
and she went through a whole thing I
literally had to call Jake for his
expertise because she was like do I need
her restart did I ruin my ability to get
AG wet card it was about Quinn why I
came home and I was like did you hear
and she was like max her husband she's
like max told me I can't play it until I
finished The Witcher 3 I was going to
buy Kentucky route zero and also Doody
shop and then I saw I saw the throne
breaker and I was like did they announce
this little business what happened was
this early
they'd set and then I checked Twitter
and in CD Projekt RED people were like
surprised yeah it's out now and I was so
excited that made my day yesterday I
feel like we probably all know Radek
like that was very sneaky cuz radix is
like PR for CD Projekt RED said it
probably read and lo and behold there it
was just like on switch he's like hey
take a look at that it was like what the
heck man ya know a friend of mine
message means tweeting was like I can't
wait for this to I can't wait for this
to come out and I was like I already got
it it's out I'm saying now he's like oh
they're sitting out codes and I was like
no it's live yeah so I love The Witcher
3 it's like one of my favorite games
I just finished blood and wine I think
it's an amazing game probably the best
game this generation may be second best
afters all right you can stay on the
podcast yeah I hate when I hate when so
much I think it's the worst part of that
game okay as hell in The Witcher 3 the
fun thing about going when you're
playing The Witcher 3 is that by the
time like eventually you'll get good
enough cards that you'll always win I
never will great my play I started the
Witcher 3 when it came out got two
Skellig I stopped and then left it like
a year and a bit did it again start the
way to three goats kinda got stopped and
then last summer I went back and
replayed it from that safe so every time
I came up with a Gwent match I was like
no I had to play so I just skipped it
until I feel bad so I do wanna play them
for a break you see I had I spent too
much I have spent so much time playing
went I'm like because I'm definitely I
have to do everything so I'm like I want
every Gwang card like I you know that's
what Jen jet that's why Jen was like I
have to start over cuz she thought that
she wouldn't be able to get one Gwent
card because she was looking up guides
and stuff
like I think I've missed this quiet card
side to be like Jake is she missed the
Gwang card should she start over and
shakes like no you can get it and so I'm
like relaying all this information to
her well I guess he says you're fine
like you guys are insane so I'm just
really excited but but Gwent
has undergone so many changes because it
is a broken card game yeah like it's
just like our fun side thing in
different we were talking about this on
NBC today - but it's like Tom Marx was
saying that like in the in the enthrone
breaker Gwent is like two lanes only and
is like totally contextual to like
what's happening within any like
respective battle and also I I didn't
know this I didn't follow as soon I feel
so bad because like as much as I love
The Witcher as soon as I heard that
throne breaker was a quaint game was
looking at okay whatever this is not for
me and I just stopped paying any
attention to it but you know like the
the general consensus is that it's not
only a really great card game it's like
an amazing RPG that tells a really
incredible story the Queen yes not not
the one in the show I don't think no
myth yeah yeah yeah but but yeah the
story is definitely the highlight of
that game like in in to be honest some
of the because it's more like a puzzle
game I'd say than a quaint game a lot of
the dough on cuentas good but a lot of
the encounters you run into are like
here the cards you get and he and
there's there's boulders coming and they
fall down the lanes each turn like a
boulder moves closer kind of well
actually I don't know what that is but
from the prices we did you guys never
seen the video Snoop Dog the best
friends Martha Stewart oh I think this
is before it's for my 20 bit you know
Snoop Dogg films a music video at my
high school when I was in high school oh
yeah which song was it young wild & free
Shi super cool also because this has
been nagging at me for the last five
minutes
Gwen Stefani
thank you for coming in my tent you just
time like some tomorrow yeah it's good
though even if you don't like Gwen I
would recommend no get a shot of it like
I think having recently replayed or
played through blood and wine the whole
time that I was playing it I was like I
love The Witcher I love this game so
much like I love the swirl I love these
characters I'm I'm interested to play
this game because I've heard the story
is so amazing so yeah I might give it a
shot yeah it's interesting because it
takes place during I think the second or
the third book but but it takes place
entirely different events that aren't
covered in the book but they intertwined
for a bit so the way they handle that is
it's pretty cool but I definitely
recommend it I will say once again
playing on switch light like tiny screen
tiny screen the text is small the
character is small managing those cards
in figure out what they do can be a
little bit difficult especially not
having that mouse because that game was
I felt designed to have a mouse in order
to click on what cards you want to play
drag and dropping cards and and building
decks and whatnot is just easier with a
mouse there's no touchscreen I try I
don't like touching my touch on the
screen only I never touch the screen cuz
I don't like you're getting smudge
that's why you have a microfiber cloth
and I still don't like oh yeah that one
I have no other option I have to touch
the screen sure because my stylus like
an old woman
I would you get
anyway throne breaker it's out now on
switch I definitely give it a shot if
you liked The Witcher 3 and if you liked
that universe I think he'll probably
it's like a 40 hour RPG right if if you
do everything I'm I think it took like I
think it's like 30 hours or so but still
yeah
what do you know do you know how what
the price is these 20 bucks hmm easy Wow
yeah alright put that on the list
Kallie next one's all you I was gonna
say this is my second about Pokemon home
well I'm just gonna take a nap during
the summer
the Pokemon company you revealed more
information about Pokemon home and I'm
actually really excited so they revealed
like pricing plans there's like a what
you get with the free version and then
what you get with the premium version
yeah what's Pokemon home sorry
that's a good point Pokemon home is like
the equivalent of Pokemon bank for the
newer generation a Pokemon so it's like
a cloud service where you can store
Pokemon but it also has a number of
other features the main one being
trading so I the thing that like I
noticed right away is that they added
back the global trade system which is
not in Pokemon sort of shield it is it's
it was introduced in generation 4 and
it's like a you know like when you're
trading Pokemon you're usually like I'm
talking to my friend and I am saying I
have this do I need this or you're like
there's an option where you can send out
a Pokemon and get a random one in return
called surprise trade the global trade
system it's like you can say okay I have
this Pikachu and in return if it's like
if you want this Pikachu
I want a level 50 female growlithe well
you can like it you you can yeah I mean
that's just an example you probably you
wouldn't get what you wanted for a PG
but you can specify like what exactly
you want so it's really good for
completing your pokedex but it's also
really good for people who are into
collecting really good Pokemon like if
you select level one that's the level
that Pokemon hatch out of an egg so you
can excel it'll one Pokemon that gives
you a greater chance of getting a
Pokemon that someone's been breeding and
has good stats and stuff like that so
people were kind of upset that wasn't in
sword and shield cuz everybody was upset
about social that's fine and um that's
one of the trading features in Pokemon
home you can do it your from your phone
so you can just like trade whatever from
your phone there's like a there's like
switch switch version features and then
phone like mobile version features yeah
that chart was a little weird it's a
little confusing but I think the main
idea is like there's only so many
Pokemon they're going to include or
that's what game freak's been saying
like we're only gonna include so many
come on in future Pokemon games because
the roster is kind of insane and how do
you that's like too many we made too
many of them but with Pokemon home you
have the national dex so let's say they
came out with a future Pokemon game that
had a different pokedex fence or in
shield instead of like having to manage
a GTS for individual pokedex is now it's
just one main thing you do on your phone
and then from there you can transfer it
into the respective game that you want
so I think it makes sense even if it's
like a little confusing from the outset
the other thing that's really nice is
they added mass wonder trade so you can
send out 10 Pokemon at once with the
paid version and like and then get ten
random Pokemon and return but it's
really good if you're me and you're
trying to breed for a shiny pokemon you
have 500 of them and you don't want them
anymore and you don't want to do with
them and they added like you can look at
the Pokemon stats through Pokemon home
it's how you would transfer Pokemon from
let's go into sorting shield for example
so it's just nice to get more details
because they said it's launching in
February they don't have an exact date
for that but up xiv calling it just a
nice Valentine's Day ooh romance
dude I hate when games kind of
Valentine's Day it's like remember Left
Behind came on but what do you got a
view kisses the the long weekend that
weekend that's what the long weekend
several kisses several smooches maybe in
another town I'm just going to see Sonic
a bunch of times
seems like a really good weekend to me
gotta go fast
yeah baby jay-z a lot of people do in
the office I I don't want to see it so I
didn't join in on that but anyway the
last thing I want to say about Pokemon
home is that I'm sorry we're talking
about Sonic now on in like Sun and Moon
or like X&Y they're offering a free
month a Pokemon bank so you don't have
to pay for both services in order to
transfer this Pokemon to pokemon home so
that's really nice
yeah I mean I think that my thing with
Pokemon sort and shield is like I only
care about getting two roll credits and
then that's it like that's the same way
I play every Pokemon game like I want to
go through I want to beat all the gyms
and then I feel like I've done as much
as I need to do in any Pokemon game but
I do think it's nice that with the
pricier system for Pokemon home the free
version will probably allow like really
casual players like if I wanted to go
further in the game if I wanted to do
like at least like low-level training or
low-level like competitive stuff after
you watch a competitive series I will
I've already subscribed the competitive
Pokemon channel so no but I think it's
cool like you for like really hardcore
players like yourself like the option is
there to pay in and like really get the
most out of it
but then the free version is probably
totally passable totally serviceable for
people who are like especially like
you're saying you're not super hardcore
in Pokemon but the next Pokemon game
comes out you're like oh wait I have I
have already have this in my other game
I'm just gonna grab them from home and
there we go I actually never got Pokemon
bank so I never got a Pokemon bank since
subscriptions so I'm really excited that
I like won't have to pay into that yet
to finally get those Pokemon off because
I that's cool and I did a bunch of
competitive breeding in Sun Moon in
particular and alpha sapphire and it'll
be nice to finally get those off like I
have a like a perfect I have a bunch of
perfect Pokemon that are the sauna yeah
so I just like I kind of was like
waiting for something like this that's
now I can finally use them and those
Pokemon I can use to breed or I could
even like take Pokemon that weren't
perfect but like if I had a shiny now I
can change the nature because sword and
shield doesn't there's there's it's I'm
glad I waited on that in the end aren't
all Pokemon perfect no no not Luvdisc we
don't we don't talk about cheeks yeah
true yeah I hope we get an actual
release what's your luck they'll
announce it like tomorrow just before we
publish I know
god um I'm just I'm imagining like it'll
just be like surprise it's out now it
comes out with that first DLC they said
February
yeah
for the first one for Pokemon Pokemon
home say one day in February so it could
be February 28th and the first deal I'm
really excited for that day you'll see
like I'm so excited to play that cuz
it's good there's like a whole there's
like a little like more thing you get to
do I'm excited
are you interested in until Co someone
who's you're just trying to get to real
credit credit roll credits I've really
fallen off that game I I went through
the fifth gym yeah the fifth gym and I
was really really into it at first but
it's very linear even compared to like
it really just like you can really just
steamroll that whole game nice and it's
they made a poke that Pokemon game was
made for hardcore players like it's
super easy to go through it which is
funny because it's the hardcore players
that are so upset about it it's not like
it isn't it isn't like if you look at
like the competitive like the VGC
players like the official championship
circuit players like they their
subscribers on youtube are soaring like
they're really yeah they're getting tons
of followers like me swab like the
competitive like competitive pokemon in
the the official championship rule set
and everything is one of the most
wholesome and good communities I've ever
experienced I've been to the World
Championships every year since 2015 in
Boston and it's like so wholesome and
there I mean there's there's drama but
like people people are just really into
the strategy of Pokemon and Pokemon in
general and a lot of those people see
the value of not having every single
Pokemon in this game - I've noticed
which is is something I cuz yeah it is
hard to break down right because you've
got I don't say to casual people but the
people who just kind of play pokemon for
the story every year maybe try to catch
them all they're mad because they don't
get all the Pokemon but then the people
who have always wanted to do like
competitive the competitive scene
they're more into this because it's
easier to do that and I would say that
the main game being easy is just here's
your cake walk to get to the end
whereas like in and it's it's less
important now that they've added those
things where you can kind of perfect a
Pokemon but like in Sun and Moon they
had ultra beasts in the Sun and Moon
Championship Series
they allowed legendaries like they don't
not every year they don't allow
Legendary's every year they did in like
not in 2016 but in 2017 I think and if
you had already caught them you'd have
to restart the game to get the ones you
need okay so like it was a pain in the
ass and a lot of people didn't admit it
but they had to resort to hacking in the
Pokemon and in a way that it frustrated
me I didn't really play a lot at that
time cuz I was like I I first of all if
I get caught doing that I am toast but
like I also don't really I don't want to
corrupt my game or anything like that I
want to risk that but now like I'd have
to restart the game in order to get
Pokemon that I could use um you don't
have to do that anymore but it's nice to
be like if I wanted to replay the game
to get something in particular and reset
for something it wouldn't be the biggest
deal to do that it would be like well I
go through the the main story but it's
it's a straight shot so it really does
seem to me like they made this game for
the really hardcore people yeah but I
think the DLC like the DLC seems to
offer some of the the old when the older
Pokemon games were you could we talked
about this on the podcast several
episodes ago like going into the caves
and solving puzzles and doing stuff that
sounds like it's coming in the DLC so I
hope that that for people because I love
it i i've played sword and shield more
than any pokemon game from the last ten
years
dang i met our 250 whoa that's crazy
congratulations thank you yeah good on
you really like no anyway moving on
apex legends had quite I don't know
quite the bait-and-switch as I have here
yeah for their hero I actually have been
following a piece for season 4 it's
coming it's called a simulation and
so basically what's happened is data
miners a while ago found references to a
new legend called Forge and they were
like oh well Forge is gonna be in season
4 and then apex were like yeah Forge is
coming he's white doom fist yeah except
his robot arm is on the other side and
then they were all hyping up this and
then they did they released this like
cartoon interview where Forge gets
killed by another character small Cronin
revenants also been in the it's husband
a mind before references to death to
revenant and to now everyone's like what
the hell like the introduces character
said he's coming to season four then
they killed him off and so now I think
revenants gonna be early that's what
that is this like a GE thing at people
who are like there's not enough white
man I didn't I don't know I think it's
honestly a cheeky dig overwatch because
the way right Oh what I'm so sorry to
bring this back too much every time but
I just talk about what you know like
overwatch when they introduced Sombra
that was an absolute bloody nightmare
but like the playerbase hated because
they knew she was coming they knew and
the character was and Blizzard were like
oh here's another sneaky thing it's like
oh here's another T's for summer and
it's like we'll know it's gonna be like
just release the character already or
just like release the developer update
that says it's gonna be Sombra so in my
mind I don't know if anyone from respawn
whatever administers like a cheeky piss
take at that
I think it's unrelated because Hammond
as a company referenced in titanfall 2
when was titanfall 2 2016 yeah so this
must be just completely unrelated but
it's like there's a lot of stuff about
forge and it's like at the Hammond
Hammond company but I haven't obviously
being character in overwatch I don't
know that's just a fun parallel but you
know it's poking fun its subverting
expectations
excited I'm excited too for was doing
actually Jordan wrote a really good
article on games about this week so you
can check we should link it in the
description about how apex is really
embracing storytelling yeah and just
using it to sort of like constantly just
subvert expectations and like treat the
play ablai the player base I've had it
be who are like following it at the same
time like people are obviously data
mining and leaking and so there's it's
kind of a way for them to take a little
bit of ownership back I think I like
apex a lot I play most weekends I may be
not as invested in the story stuff as I
am can you call overwatch his story a
story yeah absolutely I don't know
overwatch is a problem or it's like yeah
we're gonna have this big Marvel
Cinematic Universe
esque story and it just seems to be like
random pieces coming in and out and it's
yeah there's like that whole overwatch
to announcement wherever it is like
women when is this taking place it's
weird and so apex like fully committing
to telling stories and doing them in a
weird way and like playing with
marketing and kind of going the complete
opposite of everyone else who just like
like they spoil moments from their games
and marketing most of the time whereas
apex are like no scream I think it's
really funny like you have it down here
as the bait and switch and I think
that's so smart because like the
developers are even out there like doing
you know character walkthroughs with
skill set and this is what the character
is like and blah blah blah and like they
knew the whole time that characters
killed off in a specific character like
that's so funny in such a clever way to
like keep players on their toes and I'm
I'm not invested in apex I played a lot
when it came out but this is the kind of
thing that I'm like that's really
interesting the kind of stuff that
they're doing to set themselves apart
from the over watches of the world and
yeah well I'm gonna talk about what I
know Rainbow six siege which is a game
that I play a lot of but man at the
beginning of every year I feel like they
leak every single operator that's gonna
come for the rest of the year and if it
doesn't get leaked at the beginning of
the year it'll get leaked like I don't
know a month or two
before the next the next group of
operators supposed to come out and and
it is like it's so hard getting excited
for those just because it's like
basically the only thing I do when I
show up to see what they are is like
just confirming whether or not these
these leaks are true and I feel like 9
out of 10 times it's like yeah that's
what that's what was said yeah it's
exciting sing what they're doing I hope
I hope other developers you know take a
page from that and maybe try to make I
don't know especially with these games
that have already been out for a while
and they've already had like they've
already done their whole marketing
campaign multiple times over and over
and you might as well do something
different have some fun with it you know
shake up expectations totally talk about
apex then you know they were in a while
right like that definitely got the
conversation started up again I'm very
glad pre-play as most so I goes between
lifeline and octane my one thing with
apex is that I love playing it but I
don't get the wins as often so I have to
balance it with overwatch where where
you're where you always get wins played
than it is in apex and it's sort of like
the reward is more readily a parable
readily apparent
I've had two beers maybe let's go with
apex the one thing I wish you could
change is that I wish you could mute
voice lines Simon yeah Simon Katya
friend the show plays as Mirage and
Mirage is voiced by the excellent Roger
Craig Smith who yes and just great job
but I can't hear those four signs yeah
and also God Bangalore you don't need to
explain what every single bloody thing
does I just don't care I don't care what
she commute that respawn you're watching
just give me the option yeah let's do
question yeah let's get on the listener
questions Kali
the first one I want to do the second
one the second one loose is you only the
first one shot uh also you can email us
at after dot podcast at Gamescom please
send us questions we love getting
correspondence hello everyone it's still
a big fan of the show
now the next-gen is approaching and more
and more Triple A games which are over
watched Diablo cetera are coming to
switch do you think there will be a
switch Pro that's all I have to ask
great listening to you and now watching
as well every week take by idea from
Istanbul hello thanks again yeah and
thank you for sticking with us yes I
think it's coming yeah 100% there may be
a switch bro
I think more it's like a discussion of
win yeah what do you think it's gonna
come to but breath I imagine because
there were rumors that it was gonna come
this year I think that's a little too
soon me too because they switch light I
feel like it's still pretty fresh that's
still selling a lot and is same with the
original switch I feel like they'd want
to give it a little bit more time
I think it's breath of the wild to end
of this year and then switch Pro
probably like holidays and spread the
wild to end of this year switch pro if
they would keep the same Kris didn't
breath of the walk come out like mom
March 2017 yeah launch day yeah I'd
wonder if they would maybe keep that
same release date too I mean not the
Nintendo ever would purposely move out
of his spot for something like cyberpunk
and all the other games there all the
other Western games that typically come
out towards the end of the year I would
wonder cuz I mean animal crossings are
big March I mean I'm so ready see maybe
yeah no I think I think breath of the
wild to because it is like the Majora's
Mask to breath of the wilds Ocarina of
Time I think that they're probably like
reusing a lot of those assets and like a
lot of that map and I think that game is
coming a lot sooner than we think and I
think it's probably their big holiday
release and then yeah I think holiday
2021 it's probably when they'll talk
about switch bro where's Bayonetta 3
though Bennett of 3 probably like summer
next year yeah Evan in the back made a
really good breakdown of
the breath the wild to trailer hmm nice
that has definitely worth checking out
if you're excited for breath the wild to
which I am thanks for the shoutout
way to go yeah switch bro definitely
happening yeah yeah I'm ready okay okay
let's hear it I just really like this
question because it's it's very in-depth
hello after dark crew I have devised a
short test that will tell us a lot about
your personalities I hope it works this
is in bolt imagine the four of you are
participating in a very small 40 mario
tennis doubles invitational in the
Mushroom Kingdom
lap one you must select one of the
following characters as your partner
explained your choice in the case of a
repeat the best explanation gets the
partner they desire you must select from
this list and only from this list one
Mario to Luigi three Wario for waluigi
take a step back and decide which
pairing would sorry step two take a step
back and decide which pairing would win
this hypothetical Transworld tournament
I hope this exercise is fun chill hype
vibes for life Thank You Jacob McCourt
ache a wholesome Jacob Jacob a great
nickname y'all gave me last year London
Ontario Canada thank you wholesome Jacob
I love I this question is like a pop
quiz a teacher roommate and I love it so
much anyway I'm gonna go with Luigi so
I'm gonna go wait you better explain why
well so I'm going with like a mid-weight
partner right kind of an alt like
all-around tennis player so like you
know Wario is he's a heavy he's he's all
power mm-hmm
Luigi is always balanced what I like
about Luigi is that he is more humble
than Mario like like Luigi's not gonna
steal my thunder you know like this kind
of a pushover right you can't boss me I
kind of like tell him what to do and he
would do it but also like oh yeah I tell
you he's yeah
so I awesome a big fan of his his many
properties that are haunted so that's
why I'm going with I would like to
choose waluigi i feel generally like a
spiritual connection to him also he's
very long he's got a lot of reach i'm
very lanky
yes that's what I'm saying so we've got
a lot of like between the two of us ever
it doubles yeah that's a lot of coverage
this is my answer this is why I was like
I want to get in there and then snaked
you and here's things so he's also like
a little devious you know like I feel
like he's like but he's not as devious
as Wario so like he would like he would
he would sell you he'll he'll like you
told about you and take your show why
would you will walk to the line of what
would be considered like dirty playing
but he won't you know he wouldn't cross
yes exactly I'm helping you too much hmm
but then so I would also pick one of you
for the same reasons is that he's very
long I'm also long I also used to play
tennis so I feel like waluigi i could
keep under control
i could share my strats i used to play a
lot of doubles although i was not a mmm
i don't like sharing so i wasn't that
great a double good at singles but
waluigi
he's got the reach he's got the range
but the thing is is like tennis these
days hawkeye you can't get away with
[ __ ] like i think you just won the
best explanation i used to work at the
National Tennis Association really all
right
as a cleaner but
I mean that's odd uh-huh no but I used
to play a lot of tennis when I was in
school and then this is a fun little
Segway is that when I moved to London I
didn't have a job I was doing like some
freelancing for a GameSpot actually
because it was just after my internship
and my roommate at the time who's now a
published author which is very strange
she'll see me Daniel Dwyers roommate
Karolina Donahue worked for a job' she's
from she's from Island and then she
moved over and the Tuffy knew Danny is
there any way she I lived with her and
she was like you like tennis and I went
yeah and I've got a job for you and I
would have to travel over an hour each
way and basically pay more for my train
fare that I would get paid for working
in this place and I was essentially like
park cleaner part receptionist part
admin person and the National Tennis
Association and the the lawn and Tennis
Association the LTA which was and I met
Andy Murray's mum Oh Andy Murray
wait Sharapova no I didn't meet her I
did meet Greg Rusedski
who's a famous Canadian tennis player
who for some reason played for England
you don't see here in America we really
don't care about anybody there and so I
don't know who that is Greg Rusedski
comforted me as I was crying because I
read komak four coffees the road and the
look is pretty devastating so that's my
fun story about your short she picks
waluigi as well I was reading in the
break room in the last three pages of
that book a so devastating that I just
started crying and it's lovely Canadian
man come fit me and then I realized is
Greg Rusedski I that's my fun story Jake
who do you pick I mean I was gonna pick
Wario because I feel like he'd cheap
until we ran so I don't I use keep
saying keep saying I know what that
means
poor guy is he's an Avenger
they basically track the ball with
console but do you think the much um has
this you wanna get yeah yeah they have
you can get three I think it's purse at
I want to say it's purse anyway and you
can call a challenge if you think the
ball was you know in when it was out or
out when it was in and everyone says and
goes oh and then you wait and see the
balls in or out and it's look the UK
doesn't have much else to be proud of
right now it was I mean the action of
our sports we put the camera on sexy
tell yeah well I do want to say I played
a lot of Virtua Tennis and that's where
I I know I don't I want to add that I am
I am like a tanky I'm very powerful you
know I'm hard to knock over and that's
why I picked I just want to add that so
yeah you you that your whole thing is
that he would cheat he he would pride
cheat and we'd either win or we'd get
disqualified and I'm sure would be a
good time either way right
so this that's all I got second part of
this question is that we have to take a
step loose of course
Waluigi so that by default on mario yeah
got it yeah this is I get part of this
have to take a step back from our from
learning a lot about Lucy and decide
which Perry would win I mean me so I'd
obviously win because Mario always wins
no I'm gonna say if you're clear that
I'm the only person who knows the rules
of tennis I played tennis briefly and I
was very bad at it I only did it because
um I thought it would make people like
me more
that's why anybody does anything so I
think we're just gonna default to loose
I mean Jacob I think Jacob should be
then the sounding in this the final I
would love to you see from definitely I
get it cuz you're Jake yeah yeah I would
love wholesome Jacob yeah as your you
are are not wholesome Jake yeah emails
fact let us see Jacob in pure Jacob um
so that's that on that yeah right in the
show let us know who you who you chose
after next question mhm hey after dark
crew going into the next generation
are there any marketing practices you
would love to see go away I would be
very happy to never see an announcement
of an announcement ever again my
runner-up is days long twitch streams
where nothing happens for 99% of the run
time thanks that second one yes I feel
like falling states kind of ruin that
death stranding did a similar thing
where they did like a 9 hour stream on
Twitch where it was like revealed
gameplay like very short depending on
the number of people that were watching
and yeah my pet peeve it's mostly about
movies but games do this too is that
they format their trailers and you get a
mini trailer ahead of the big trailer
which is works for Twitter because
autoplay you want to grab people in but
then they don't change that for YouTube
for theatrical trailer and it's super
annoying
and learn how to use social media please
my pick is the surprise release
for a game that I then need to assign
someone to review I don't want you to do
that anymore
it stresses me out a lot it makes my job
really hard and I don't like it when
it's like here's a game we're announcing
and it's out today especially at e3
we're busy you think I have time to
review that God paying youtubers to say
nice things about your game yeah that
one I don't like that was gonna be mine
as well
info sorry yeah influencers that are
paid to be like yeah drew if you ever
seen that video that um I know you're
gonna talk about it yep uh a youtuber
has a slow realization yeah I don't even
remember who it was and it's this guy
talking about Assassin's Creed syndicate
and he's like going on and on he says
you know Ubisoft aren't paying me to say
nice things about this game well they
brought me out here and well they're
paying for my meals and yeah I guess
they did it's like this is very like
slow realization of it's very strange
but also there's yeah SAS is Creed
syndicate underrated assassins it's
great I have the platinum in that one
that's the only Assassin's I have a pod
well you're contractually obligated on
account of being so British but yeah in
between episodes of the crown never seen
the crown and charter you lie back I
just want to make sure we've all seen
Friday Night Lights I value the American
yes that is the American something I
don't know no no way you can see neither
of them you you haven't see Friday I had
a boyfriend who made me you can tell
when I'm sad is because I contemplate re
watching Gilmore Girls mmm last time I
did it was 2017 could happen bummer I'm
gonna keep an eye on you for that one
thank you okay - I'm at six last Q I
want steak for oh I forgot to be the
name oh wait I can set right I'll do it
um howdy after doc Wow the dog Maire
from shits
howdy after-dark boys and gals I didn't
really have a good question but I just
wanted to write in to tell you all how
much I've been loving the podcast
anyways I guess I'll ask a question
though since I'm writing in so if
hypothetically you could only play one
game for the rest of your life which
game would you choose and why
sidenote now that we have video episodes
can someone from your team please edit
the know anime penguin over Jake space
any time the crew gives an anime tangent
it's what the people need Jake's the
ones who edits the podcast so he has to
do that himself
no that is written by Joshua and I dish
from Florida Davie underscore George so
I can only imagine that's what he's been
is by the underscore Georgia from
Florida so I can only say that as a
Goofy's George oh I know him he's a good
dude only Josh in Florida I am gonna
right now I'm gonna say Pokemon because
I could just keep playing competitively
and that's the competitive game of the
night but I when I first read this
question I was I felt stardew valley in
my heart
mmm that's a good one that's a good pig
yeah Starman farm game
[Music]
battery I don't know which like I wish I
wish I had to think harder about that
shocking that you would choose that like
witcher 3 is the obvious one right but i
feel like a game like Rainbow six siege
is something that I like keep coming
back to just because they keep adding
more content all the Witcher 3 is like
it's done I've played through it
multiple times I probably don't I could
probably don't even play that game
anymore even though I like playing it
more probably do you think I've seen
everything in that game I am pretty
confident I have except at least in
terms of like story and quest stuff mhm
there's some like perfect parts of the
map I haven't been stuff like no not
Hut's hunts like beast hunts and stuff
that you can like just like bounties
yeah do you think I said Hut's yeah I
heard something else the c-word that's
what I heard probably see a lot of those
in that game to be honest you don't you
actually just see boobs okay I did
literally last night we had like a girls
night at my house and I explained to
everyone see where this is going because
one of our friends did not believe that
that could happen right in like they're
really going for it
so that was fun that was a big part of
our night great um so anyway Witcher 3
cuz you can make no I was saying
probably not Witcher 3 because I've seen
almost every game has I probably go with
room with six seed because that's a game
that they keep updating and I still play
that fairly consistently but I don't
know maybe we would change
I see I don't know if I would pick
something that like I like really love
for a nostalgia factor and I could just
play over and over again like breath of
the wild I've played multiple times and
could easily pick it up and play it over
and over again or if I would play
something that is like challenging and
really mechanically fun to play like
something like blood-borne Oh
Metal Gear Solid 5 maybe I think I
probably picked Brent in the wild I
think I'd like one game to play for the
rest of time and I don't necessarily
feel like I'd be like constantly playing
it but I could definitely get that
hankering once a year and be like okay
I'm gonna spend you know 60 to 100 hours
just doing everything this game has to
offer
yeah I love that game very much hell no
Andrew got him all new he did get them
all friend of the podcast he got them
all didn't he was it was it Brian altano
who got them all before even came out
was it done Reichert I think it was Dan
Reicher they got him all before I came I
don't know that all ton I've ever got
them all though they're only two people
in our office that I think got all of
them and that's Josh do and and Andrew
yeah really Josh do yeah that was like
the only game that Josh do you played
for like a year and a half yeah yeah
breath of the wildest yeah that's my
pick I would never get all the croc
seeds though I mean I guess I would it
just bums me out that I know what the
reward is and it's just nothing
piece of [ __ ] yeah I actually I wrote
the guy spoilers for breath of the West
I wrote the guide for like how to find
court not like how to find them all but
like what to look for and I got like a
like I got more than I think was
necessary but it was still like 300 400
yeah I think I'm like I win a very long
time without finding any really I went
yeah I want a very long time without
finding any and I I was like do these
things and I don't seem because I didn't
I guess I didn't know what I was looking
for my freaking guide probably but I
didn't and that's why it took me so long
to find in you I demoed that game at e3
2016 and one of the first things that
you can do is like
climb all the way up the chapel the the
temple of time and so like you go all
the way to the top of it and there's a
there's a core Ock that just appears
right at the top and that's usually the
first one that everybody finds and when
I found it in the demo the Nintendo
person that was giving me the demo was
like like didn't know if I was supposed
to have found it and I was like is that
a core cuz I'm Wind Waker is my favorite
game of all time and that's the game
that they're from yes like Sakura
did you find these like how many are
there and she was like I don't know I
can't say hi I was playing Pokemon let's
go and I pulled up the menu there was
like no one around me knows that many
and oh I didn't even think about it like
I wasn't trying to but like all of a
sudden I hear like someone's stomping
over like you did you can't do it you
gotta get got to get rid of the menu and
I was like I'm sorry I didn't mean to
right Chloe capturing meanwhile
capturing I'm here to find out how many
stats they have I had that I was at one
in Montreal and demoing Arkham origins
and I pulled up the trophy list never
heard of purpose and move faster in that
life like no don't do that spoiled my my
favorite demo that I ever did was at the
Nintendo booth in 2015 for Star Fox zero
and I was so awful at it I was so bad at
it cuz that game is very hard to control
anyway but like I was just crashing into
[ __ ] just like just barreling through
stuff and just rolling and just playing
like playing so poorly in the gym the
poor woman giving me the demo was like
hey finally finally I pause it and I was
like you don't have to do all that I
know I'm doing bad and she was like okay
the exactly things so that year our
stage was opposite it's always near
Nintendo yeah and I got in early and it
was the only game yeah I could get on
before I had to do host the stage stuff
and so I got on could not get on board
at the gyroscopic controls at all
crashing into everything and the guy
just went do you just want the badge
yeah
I'll just alright yeah being bad at the
demo is always really embarrassing it's
like I you know I'm bad every video game
to like begin with so it's free yeah I
know what to expect going into it
there's no tutorial for this demo you
being like the a button does this in the
people and does this and I'm like I
that's not how I learned yeah you you
think you're like I was like before I
worked here I was like oh yeah I think
I'm pretty good at video games like and
you see game playa online from when I
was like got IGM game so I'm like I
could play these games better and now
that I'm actually doing it I'm like oh
yeah it's because a lot of times you
don't get a tutorial you don't go
through they're just like here's the
level we want you to play and you spend
the first ten minutes trying to figure
out the controls and you spend the next
ten minutes like getting used to the
world and then that's all you can carry
it's like alright now publish this yeah
and it makes that work well now
everyone's gonna think umm but if you
well know have you ever had the opposite
of that where you're like really good at
a demo yeah yeah yeah when I did when I
demoed Link's Awakening last year that's
one of my favorite games of all time and
it's like a one to one remake and I just
like blew through the first dungeon and
at the end of the day the demo the guy
was like huh
you really know this game pretty well
huh yes I do sir there was something I
demoed were like most people didn't
finish the thing there's something they
were like well that was with the Last of
Us - I talked about on this podcast but
I finished I was the first one done with
the demo and I like looked around like
oh yeah I'm the first one I stand up and
then Neil druckmann walks - I was really
fun to watch you play you do that fast
and I was like noticed anyway that's
been episode 26 of GameSpot after dark
thank you so much for tuning in and make
sure to subscribe to GameSpot on YouTube
if you're watching it on YouTube or if
not do that anyway Thank You Zack for
coming by I think for having me this is
really fun
where can people find you on put ya on
Twitter I'm at Zacharias T and I am all
over IGN's social media as well and I'm
on NVC Nintendo voice chat every
Thursday at 3 p.m. Kali how about you um
you can find me on Twitter I'm sorry
at Enki tojiko I am KY DOJ ikk oh you've
been hearing that way long ago I want to
change it so bad but everything I want I
love it and not just for the jingle dude
thrill hose taken and I'm slow by
someone who doesn't tweet that's your
thrill ho if you're at thrill home on
Twitter fight me I want that so bad 1v1
me bro getting rid of like Dolman
account so - there's somebody has at
Cali hasn't tweeted since 2014
so anyway that's my Twitter handle um
like I said I'm working on the
competitive Pokemon kind of a short
series and I'm excited about that
mmm that's me Lucy I was just thinking
is Lucy mad because she runs the series
video no I'm not mad I just need to pee
this is my you know the episode of
Simpsons Oh grandpa Simpson's kidneys
just burst that's like me as James
Instagram the whole lot this week we
doing any episode of audio logs with
David DeAngelo from Yacht Club games all
about the games that inspired shovel
knight but most important like the
unloved and forgotten mechanics but
inspired Sheldon I it's very interesting
it's in the Edit right now and it's
probably one my favorite episodes today
to look out for that and you can find me
at jacob deck on twitter i think that's
about oh and make sure to email us at
after dark podcast that gamespot.com for
your questions or you can tweet it in
any one of us well I don't know I guess
if someone tweets at you with questions
you can just slow it down but yeah all
right see y'all next week
[Music]